[Music]
[Music]
in 1989
a group of scientists was assembled to
decode the human genome under the
direction of dr james watson
one of watson's big motivations here was
to try to recruit
the best and brightest from many
different disciplines biology but also
physics chemistry engineering
because all of those would have to get
together if this was going to work
many of the biologists and i love them
dearly of course
were dragged into it kicking or
screaming in the beginning because they
they failed to see the tremendous value
that such an enterprise would provide
the field the talent turned out to be
all over the world
so you have to basically make it
possible for those bright minds to get
engaged
where they are they're not going to all
move to join this effort
genomics has fundamentally changed the
way we do science
it brought the notion of team science
and collaboration to biology here's
think about collaboration it's also
intensely competitive
each person wants to achieve
something personal you know they want to
make their hit you know on the problem
but then immediately they want to share
it with the other and the other learns
immediately
and so you you ratchet each other up
from the beginning of the genome project
there was a fairly strong sense of
enthusiasm in the public sector
the private and academia
we had lots of support from republicans
partly because
newt gingrich was interested in science
and i knew it there's no partisan
difference in everybody wanting to live
as long as they can
i think there's a lesson there it isn't
a
monolithic project it was a big
challenge but it brought people together
and i think that's what we have to do in
the future
[Music]
when the human genome project was
started it's important to note the
technology of sequencing
was not developed yet so it's in a sense
a project that was launched with a wing
and a prayer we couldn't sequence it at
that time the
machines were nothing like fast enough
there were no machines even it was
sequencing was done by hand i thought we
might have to do it brute force and
i was quietly prepared to use the
old-fashioned technology
just because it was so important to get
it done
there are a lot of things you know that
would make life easier
that just hadn't been invented yet it
would be
a 100-year project like monks working to
copy a book
at best
[Music]
bit by bit we got into more and more
large scale sequencing
but the sequencing is enormously
important because it provides the
possibility of searching by computer
[Music]
when i showed up at washington
university one day with a
computer terminal under my arm
people looked at it and said what are
you going to do with that
it's a genetics department genomes were
supposed to be too complex to be able to
reassemble them in the computer without
computers we
simply would be dead in the water
computers and genomics were made for
each other
genetic information is digital it's like
binary code it just happens to use
four digits instead of two
[Music]
it is amazingly accurate and that's what
biology gets
from digital information
the human genome project contributed a
cultural change about data sharing
because the genome project was about
sharing data almost immediately
and while it seems obvious now it wasn't
obvious then that required
significant effort i think i'm quite
lucky as a scientist because i grew up
always sharing data the community around
me
the genomics community the worm and fly
communities as well
it's just a default that you're going to
share everything
you're going to share the code you're
going to show everything by publishing
but you're going to share it before
publishing you're going to share
half-cooked ideas
and in fact this is a wonderful thing
it's liberating it would been
virtually criminal to try to hoard
discoveries
that meant the difference in life and
death in people this is information
which we'll be using for centuries
the sooner we get it and everybody has
access to it who wants it
the faster we can move in terms of
understanding how life works and
how disease occurs
[Music]
patients invest a certain degree of fear
about genetics who's going to find this
out how will it be used against me
a lot of the ethical and social
considerations that we're struggling
with today really have historical roots
in the early 1900s in the united states
where we had
many states that had laws that allowed
us to forcibly
sterilize people and prevent them from
having children based on whether we as a
society felt that they were
genetically fit so at the beginning of
the human genome project
we got it right of bringing in the
social scientists the ethicists the
lawyers
and we now have helped to provide a
whole generation
of scientists that are focusing on the
ethical and social issues of genomics
[Music]
the sequencing of the human genome was a
monumental achievement
decades of work thousands of scientists
billions of dollars
and we get this first roadmap for what
makes up
the human genome it's an incredibly
exciting moment
at the same time it's just the beginning
of
what's really a much longer voyage and
let's again be
audacious but let's not be unrealistic
about what's possible
i think the next 10 years are going to
see some exciting developments in
genomics particularly those
who start to use genomic information as
part of routine medical care
and that'll be applied to dealing with
diseases like cancer
hypertension diabetes and alzheimer's
disease
i dream of the day when every young
mother brings a young girl or young boy
home from
the hospital with a little jean card and
they said this is the way you should
prepare this child's health care
[Music]
it's exhilarating
[Music]
you